attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge
[Musique]
tu as vu la fille la belle est pas mal
hein pas mal ces missiles heureux je la
vois tu penses quoi
nantes a aucune chance à temps c'est
vrai de madrid la main plutôt voir les
stars année et juin j'ai l'impression
qu'ils ont rien depuis tout à l'heure
oui parce qu'en fait ils tâchent la
soeur de chemise on met et si je te paye
inverse il va se passer quelque chose
après non je pense pas par contre je
veux bien vert gratuit quand même ok
monsieur au point du matin avec du truc
le moins cher que vous ayez ce qu'on
voit pas ken j'ai envie de me bonne
parce que je suis bourré qui veut dire
non parce que je perds attention excuse
moi j'en parlais mais comme tu es
beaucoup trop belle pour moi je suppose
que j'ai aucune chance benjamin fait
comme si une bombe est maître espagnol
avoir à oui mais par contre je pense que
tu es plus belle qu'intelligente matin
et avec des sketches avec 4 à ça ça peut
intéresser mes parents et là tu vois par
exemple je cherchais un sujet
inintéressant pour meubler la
colonisation mais en vrai j'ai juste
envie de regarder tomber côté bazire
donc ça que j'ai l'habitude d'en voir
plus clair et thiam cholet ce moment
numéro
tel un chantier on sait jamais ah ouais
nan faut pas me dire des trucs comme ça
si moi je suis déjà en train de tomber
amoureux de toi donc si jamais il se
passe un truc entre nous but est plus
belle que moi je vais devenir jaloux
possessif peut-être même que je vais
quitter mon travail pour d'espionner la
journée ahmed a fait il ya peu de
chances que je te rappelle le pit a une
tache de si non la jsr l en avant
guingamp table de restaurant
merde à tous les coups ça va être pour
nous dany brillant et franck ribéry
[Musique]